[Music]
the directors that you've worked with
you know I know that you're always
trying to learn stuff and take lessons
away from everything you do who is one
of the mentors to you or who is somebody
that you learned a lot from or watched
very closely I think I want to learn a
lot of things from American director
like Steve Spielberg Lucas James Koepp
Cameron but I can't they they just too
good
they took over all a computer and with
all the Hollywood system there's so many
professional people stay just so good
and I I cannot learn things this day
from American director because I don't
know so I really learn a lot of thing
from the old day Buster Keaton Harrell
oh yeah
no no computer graphic nothing just do
the real things I said oh okay that's
easy clock a wire yeah bad lie lie I
remember a few years ago gentleman
invite me to his set to see avatar then
I go inside I go to the set nothing on
the set then then I look at this is 300
something's camera on the top and all
computer graphic people standing up they
treat me like a master Jackie Chan I
pretend I pretend they sit down and the
guy kept talking to me never really real
and they take give me a monitor okay
anytime you wanna stop okay stop yeah
actually I don't know anything
boom the there's things coming up I see
so many people in the computer in my
monitor but outside nothing I can on
your shoulder on I can on your Tai Chi
shot I just and I see so many people sit
on the
okay I said America very cool now I go
to the set to see James Cameron and sit
there Jim topic
a big fat then gyms keep talking ah no
no the camera I don't know nothing
3d camera why the lens like this I know
you I think mostly people thought Jackie
Chan speak good English and except some
people really know me Jackie can you
come here
would you like some soup no like James
Cameron he thought I'm I'm a busy you
know jackie miranne uh-huh
that's all tell me I said I don't want
to bother you I know you so busy I have
to go away
I thank you so much